rap handler e what's up mmm
titanfall twos up oh nice one uh so this
morning we were waiting for a glitch in
the frontier update which would add a
bunch of new things right a new map a
new mode new assassination two new maps
I believe the other one being a live
fire map but it looks like just like a
changeup of like that cargo area from
the last two that were dropped for the
last update cool I'll probably get right
into it going for about an hour today
maybe a little more I'm just gonna play
title two like I said we're gonna do
that this morning but finally pretty
much just updated on your account so
yeah I was watching this on xbox one ps4
PC you could pretty much get into this
right now if you want to yeah I think I
saw people in the chat saying along with
us
yeah it's downloading for a lot of
people still cool yeah I was just
hitting the subreddit this refresh
refresh refresh on apparently I think
was rumored that there they found a
glitch which works out over the update
responded yeah and their update so they
can out you know you gotta you know take
the time if you need it but yeah first
thing that I noticed is that's a cool
new intro isn't that cool
it's cool and apparently I saw in the
patch notes that no longer when you load
up the game does it start on campaign a
lot of quality of life here things so
just go straight to the multiplayer menu
it's the last you touched oh yes I mean
I haven't played campaign in many months
if people had watching him not you
should it's a fantastic it is a very
awesome campaign but that's not over
here for today we're not we got new
stuff so I already made a class that is
going to help us get the new execution
because Mikey we're gonna need to kill
ten pilots with the pulse blade
good luck I have Rob I play this game a
lot pulse blade is one of my main
loadout items I have never killed a
single person I don't think I'd have to
double-check the stats to make sure I
haven't done what I'm noticing mmm
awesome so here's another cool thing is
Oh randomly chosen execution that's cool
I like that so if you know of the prey
executions that were you know specific
to the prey chasis chases whatever now
you can test this now you can uh now you
can swap them out or go Rando pretty
neat
uh yeah yeah and as usual those you
joining YouTube twitch Oh came spot I've
got those chats up so throw some
questions at us ask Rob how it's feeling
what he likes about it uh this is the
normal questions be monitoring the chat
while Rob plays they nerf Rob shotgun
again we were joking earlier saying rob
is probably the reason they've been
nerfing in that shotgun you see on
screen right now because the Eva what
percentage of your time total in
titanfall to would you say is devoted to
using that weapon well we could find out
real well hold on before you actually
check how many odd okay that's a thirty
five hours am i doing correct man yeah
no yeah thirty five and a half hours
total like spent with that gun in your
head that's longer that's as long as
some people have been playing persona 5
the entire game Rob that's too much
there's your what I can't get enough of
it it's great yeah they nerfed it uh the
distance I have to be closer to people's
faces if I want to engage its full
potential but I think they said the
spread was increased as well they need
to counter it I don't know but whatever
yeah new faction uh looked like it's
just it's like the the trailer they
showed his uh like when you're dropping
at the beginning of the mission give the
thumbs up like a bb-8 kind of thing
almost oh sure yeah hopefully we'll see
here we go
I'm shiny lie fire so uh speaking of
campaign if you play the campaign or
like the first ten minutes you probably
recognize the inspiration behind this
map uh the gauntlet you run the time
trial thing that when they're testing
you out as a before you're a pilot right
or no yeah it's it's capped
in Lhasa mosa his whole planet I believe
it's like not I wanted to say destiny
but I know it well I just hope yep oh
you want turn that down a little bit
laughs sorry about that
oh good oh man you're just gonna be
[ __ ] fanning that pulse plate aren't
you I saw I was in the again the title
subreddit for a while people were saying
uh as but as a lot of people are working
towards it to get that unlock consider
using the gravity star to basically hold
them in place so then it makes it easier
to them wait you say yeah the gravity
stars a granade item the pulse plate is
they load out item right yeah is that
right what would you say
so the gravity's have someone else throw
gravity star how would I know no no no
no just just if you're focusing on on on
landing a pulse blade on the pilot throw
a gravity star and then the I was
wondering I was wondering if they took
up the same loadout slot but the grab
star takes up like the grenade slot
whereas the the thrown item slot whereas
the SONA takes up the actual lvl1
ability okay cool yeah that would work
um or just anything we can assassinate
someone to throw the blade time maybe
like come upon people and sure I
remember when I was in like modern
warfare 2 when they introduced the
throwing knife and I was trying to get
all those challenges and that was like a
fun week
I don't know really got know what I was
doing I was really dumb sorry guys
awesome live fires the mode they
introduced so I set couple updates yeah
it wasn't last update I kind of just
spoke earlier to it dates ago
you guys have any comments or questions
proving the chat apparently we know
nothing about this game I find a little
harsh we know something you only know
this game if it's in the shotgun
with the shotgun I like the alternator
this map looks pretty cool the trailer I
showed you this morning like really
showed it off an interesting way with
Titans right like all right yeah it
seems like as a Titan you just you could
feel a little stressed out just you
can't hold a tight mode on this map
though yeah you can't a guide enough
this is a live for specific so the other
thing that was cool is I was talking
about that one mode oh my god
the I believe it's called Titan brawl
I'm being really dumb I'm sittin like
focused on that like pulse blade stuff
and I gotta ignore it for now so I'm not
doing well at all
but yeah Titan brawl I believe is like
straight-up someone in the titanfall
subreddit like thought of it and they
just took it incorporated which is
really neat like these guys really do
listen to their community
that's cool they saw the bug today and
push it back I guess mm-hmm Jesus Jesus
the Mastiff man that gun is he may have
moved on from the Eva I this faction
kind of hard to understand him
Reilly Christianson asked on YouTube
asked you guys think he'll ever get the
generation regen 100 right what do you
add now oh my god guy I'm at Wow I
forget no I don't think so Riley me I
probably think titanfall 30 would be out
if they make one before I get there
I love this gun oh I love the alternator
oh there it is the Mozambique that gun
is pretty overpowered too and am I at
but I use it Gen 6
what are you doing not I'm not many
people mentioned but someone did ask if
you could put in the first person your
spectating would that be easier to watch
sure can you yeah there you go sir look
that's up to you get yeah it gets kind
of stuttery though in first person a
little bit house weird Jen 100 yeah
that's nuts
what that's bananas that is bananas and
that is the second time I've heard you
say that today well we were probably
talking about Jen 100 earlier no you
weren't
are you going
this map reminds me of as like as least
amount of kills like a skatepark just
like got all this you know I mean like
it's it's I think it's like the exact
opposite that'd be sick as far as their
you know the complaint of like oh
there's this like the same lanes you go
down for like the newer Maps on time
fall to eating I mean compared to like
the previous game like this is just like
definitely allows for some creativity it
feels like that's right
warfare the update is out right now go
play it well no keep this on but play
along honey I don't know if that's got
the Xbox to because once aaron our other
video producer here video producer here
is playing on pc he was like it's here
and i checked and sure enough it was on
ps4 so it rolled out for like at the
same time
damn
nicely done
[Music]
a weird standoff we're going to see a
replay of that I had the best it I
totally intention now how do you get
lost go go for it
I really should be trying to get that
pulse this is the right mode to do it
though so they switched it up the last
up there right instead of having to do
50 assassinations with the assassination
from the previous update which kind of
does an unfair confident thing damn rekt
what did they change it to last night
where they would no they just gave it to
you right I grabbed a hook one you just
got um yeah I believe so
cuz people I think complain about having
to do like 50 with a certain assessment
yeah they get they got but you wouldn't
have if you didn't do that the previous
I'm sure they got more lacks what is
[Applause]
what was he doing was that was I hate he
was stalling waiting for the flag I
think I don't know Oh cuz the flight I
think the flag had dropped rather than
running on the map and being a target I
guess
yeah even between the walls and was a
target honestly I don't I don't play
this mode that often could you tell I'm
not the biggest fan I I mean I like it
I'm like a classic titanfall
right and you can actually jump between
you know have a dichotomy between Titans
pilots but it's good that they have
options
I'm complaining about that right because
um there are new modes and they seem
really interesting just little tweaks on
like certain other modes that are
already in the game like last Titans
standing I think it's called iron am I
thinking of Titan brawl one of them is
basically just last hide in standing so
you can't eject rally christiansen curb
check was the past execution thank you
no I'm fine as with the previous
assassinations they're kind of basing it
around one of the ability items each
time so yeah the hook the phase shift
was in that triple punch this one jumped
I don't know if people have seen it but
your pilot will jump on someone's
shoulders and kind of like grip their
head with their knees and then just do a
double handed sonar pulse blade stab
into their forehead kind of like you
like at the end of winwaker but a little
more aggressive um sure yeah what else
is there some other thing there are no
James carry on you to be saying see if
tone and Roman in Prime's are out I
don't think there are no prying out an
update they are be next update oh we
could talk so we don't you want to talk
about the that like rumor we saw yeah
there are a couple rumors I saw just to
clarify we do not know anything about
like a new Titan we wish we did but this
is not like us masking any insider info
this is us we saw it was on some like
reddit thread right yeah someone had
essentially he said he opened up the
vials in the PC version and found a like
three files hit files that they sleep
that's funny three files that hinted at
a new Titan and it was called like God
dang I can't remember maybe someone in
the chat would know it was like not
brawl but like you remember that's not
cloak uh that hinted had a Titan that
basically had uh explosive punches and a
grappling hook you're asking if I
remember the name yeah I can remember
the name of what they likes him
bison that's right oh he's trying to do
it haha [ __ ]
IX no if you look it if you pay
attention just look how many like
flashing spheres of sonar pulses there
are right dude you know what's kind of
you know what they must have had to take
into account like with this update
everybody's gonna be trying that so the
[ __ ] like they must have had to
consider that that everybody's gonna
know where everybody else is cuz
everybody's using sonar blade how are
you you're like gonna barely not be
highlighted through walls and [ __ ] or on
the radar right that's good point
I'll tell you this much I am really bad
at sonar I do not use it enough also
this is capture the flag huh oh yeah
just kill everyone elimination okay I
can afford it
Oh Mike you miss it because you're
texting yo I've got I'm doing a stream
right after this uh-huh that's cool put
me in second then yeah whatever I
could've just played by myself did you
get a sonar kill yep oh [ __ ] that's what
I was saying
damnit I'm used to doing more node I
don't have text they're things the text
so this is people are saying monarch so
that's what I saw on the reddit today
was that someone was playing campaign
and and remember in the campaign at a
distance the hug will show what type of
Titan you're up against and someone like
way in the distance all like it looked
like a Titan in like a like a bunker
shooting out and it said monarch weird
yeah so people were like kind of
assuming maybe the architect now
thinking that might be it but that's
just an interesting one personally I'm
hoping for like a electric arc cuz
murder lot at last game had the arc
like you know like an EMP type Titan
maybe that's his core ability oh there
are guys everywhere
it's close throw when I didn't do
anything I was grabby sir
Oh came back out damn that's tepid oh oh
there's zip lines in this padding this
is the first map that has it that's not
live fire that has zip lines I can't
think of any other map did the remake of
the friend maybe did the remake map
first one that came out have that not
angel city nice I'm pretty sure is
applied you're tough you use them wrong
you're just this target that everybody
like to easily track yeah
[Music]
is that what this execution is called
get to the point that's pretty good if
it is I'm gonna pull up the patch notes
quick there or hold up I forgot to let
you know all right so for those just
joining an YouTube twitch or GameSpot
I'm like my heart is Rob handler he is
playing titanfall to the question of
frontier update just released on ps4
Xbox one PC a little later in the day
than we expected but that was due to
respawn entertainment kind of correcting
a bug we think so I'm not confirmed
either way I came out a little later so
what we have it um we go new featured
modes the introducing these at different
times in near future so oh really
they're not all ones so iron last Titan
standing it's the last time standing you
know love with a few new rules 5v5 with
no ejecting and no battery so that's
just a little that's what I'm thinking
of Titan brawl yeah what's that team
deathmatch with just Titans 5 V 5 modes
Titans only no ejecting and respawning
each kill accounts for one point first
teen to 30 oh so it's it's not a single
elimination you can respawn until you
get 30 points just all-out Titan kinda
that sounds pretty fun yeah marked for
death 6v6
one member which team is marked as
targets and both teams must defend their
tired while trying to kill the other
team's target that sounds a little bit
like live fire already right yeah yeah
once one of the mark players are killed
the surviving marks team is reward a
point after a few seconds new March are
chosen so it's kind like a bounty not
bound it well on this game bounty hunt
two completely different but then glitch
24/7 oh no that's just variety for this
new features main menu update you saw
increased pilot gen to 100 which someone
was asking if we already did that no not
in the last half hour I could lie fire
modes and private match options you can
now choose between regular prime or
random for execution for Titans if you
only turn
I like that I like that alright where's
the news next new execution get to the
point there you go
pulse blade unlocks after getting 10
pilot kills with a pulse plate and if
you already have 10 pills it'll either
be a month it's pretty tricky so this is
the map deck I believe is this glitch
this is the new one glitch okay some
deck is the new live fire I'm not gonna
get 10 I'm just not gonna do it not the
best mode to get it in
you should just probably do internet
normal team deathmatch where you can
sneak up on people and it's not just
everybody out in the open kind of sure
sprinting around
it's pretty freakin frantic awkward
I really like this robot doesn't say
anything he just chirps I'm still gonna
do it
he's trying it F great so what do you
think about this map so far Wi-Fi remote
on I like it yeah yeah I'm not gonna get
it I'm like oh yeah you're right I got
to stop me I got treated like an
execution yeah and this is not the best
mode to do it with people are a little
more frantic knowing they only have one
life I think when team deathmatch will
catch people off-guard more well this
isn't one life oh when the time runs out
you have to it's just like capture fly
but I kind of agree I was single not I
don't know
it's tough in a game where everybody's
moving I'll say that guy oh oh wow I'm
real good who else pretty close uh-oh
Dean gross that was gross it's that five
o'clock thing I was telling about told
Rob before I did at five o'clock have to
senator a minor thing where the person
joining me we're recording a playthrough
of Resident Evil 5 right after this not
trying to pimp it yeah you are um
tomorrow we got a big busy day yeah
really busy day uh you wanna yeah we're
gonna so talking about schedule you want
me to no yeah you go for it you talk so
uh 8:00 starting at 9:00 a.m. Pacific
time to we're gonna start playing like
old call duty World War two games for
about an hour and a half hour ish and
then what else is going to happen on
that stream the purpose of the stream is
that tomorrow if you guys know that um
you know uh sledgehammer right is doing
this one yeah slow Jeremy games Mel Duty
World War to World War two Call of Duty
going back a lot of stuff leaked but
tomorrow can be the official yeah reveal
for a lot more details so right the
stream starts at
Oh
stream starts at god I'm so bad right
now I am so bad right now
sorry god damn tomorrow 9 a.m. Pacific
will start the screen around around 10
a.m. is when the embargo drops and I
believe we'll be seeing more info on
this game including we're counting on is
a trailer for the game to which we will
watch it and you know kind of talk about
it and dissect it more or less oh look
it dang you got stuck
cuz had that so yeah it should be fun
and then right after that we're going
right into the lobby yeah Lobby our
weekly live show being robbed you'll be
on that as well both of us we're talking
about whether we want another world war
2 shooter now that they've kind of had
time to breathe and release a [ __ ] ton
of futuristic shooters oh I got about
Mario Kart oh oh my god 3 times I should
have done that uh yeah
Mario Kart 8 whether it's worth going
back to and the title swish no that's
out for that yeah you know what games
are coming out actually like they're
kind of like medium profile games until
prey hits its dawna for three is out yet
or reviews are out at least gave it an
8/10 on gamespot if you like RTS games
on one it's pretty fun I played a little
bit of it you should get into it
what remains of Edith Finch we gave it a
9 more you know like to use the
derogatory term walking simulator but
it's like a 2 or 3 hour game narrative
what else came out Oh Dragon Quest
Heroes 2 was soon which I want to play
that I watch more gameplay of it I've
been into more JRPGs even though that's
more of a dinosaur
it blends the two pretty cool hmm of
course persona 5 and breast while are
still out so you could play those as
well
oh my god and now we have title 2 up to
thank you and outlast 2 damn a lot of
games [ __ ] ok outlast 2 released we gave
it a 7 out of 10 Scott Butterworth his
last review before he left GameSpot it's
a good really good review
yeah give a would I say 7 out of 10 you
go watch that I'm gonna play that
tonight me too yeah we'll be talking
about all those on the lobby and more I
think Oh give me it a lot of stuff going
on tomorrow oh there's a guy on me damn
oh my god why am I the way I am what's
going on with this Marco Diaz and you
can chat seems like he's having he's
playing and having a really rough match
or something people keep people keep
coming comforting him mm-hmm
he was just ripped apart by six tones at
once from every angle Marco are you okay
I'm not having a very good so you're
right there with Rob yeah playing like a
damn idiot I'm just getting used to this
new map
Oh Oh cut the camera let's get off that
[ __ ] a brick uh gross sorry what
were you gonna say
um what wasn't gonna say I don't know 11
kills not nothing I just want to play
attrition and then I can relax like I've
been thrown into like the the fire more
a more or less life I people people are
like fear for this guy he got owned by
maybe four tones this is telling his
whole story just updating us some said I
should raise my fov I saw that people
you know I did the other day
maybe I didn't transfer over him I said
try that it's good advice
Johnny real apologize if I'm butchering
that asking do we think there will be a
titanfall 3 I think so I don't think
it'll be for a while no because what
respawn is working on next is the Star
Wars games
[Music]
they're making a Star Wars game
collaborating on some PowerPoint that's
good I like it
whatup Bob Jones yo what up
mark for death does sound and cool
shadow Jose I agree we'll try that out
we get the chance are you the variety
playlist or an hour yeah 24/7 glitch
this map L so that is it's gonna go
through all the mode so 24/7 glitch
doesn't mean glitching the frontier
means a specific map glitch I believe so
okay I got to that makes more sense
that's what this map is called right yep
which
god this games fun tawan alright hard
but you might have better luck with the
sonar blade now yeah a lot of campers I
would think dangerous god hate it
I'm normally decent to justice wielder
said also so I'm not seen as dirtbag
must switch to Tony my main tight switch
from tone be my main tine to Ronin I
think that goop tone mains are like the
Hanzo mains of titanfall do you're an
overwatch player well did you see what
was that one of the I'd say the bigger
updates or patches they did was they
lowered the AoE of all may melee for
Titans except for Ronin well because his
isn't a punch right it's a sure but like
I found that interesting huh so you
actually have to kind of aim a little
more when you're punching pilots or I'm
trying to do the yeah sure
you know and I wonder that you need whoa
sorry justice wielder it seems offended
that I just call it compared him about
Hanzo main that's funny oh I apologize
if I offended you
oh hey hold on are you a destiny player
Rob at all just no but I will play
destiny too yeah I grace Sutherland was
just asking him and Rayleigh Christians
ever thought yeah the thing about
destiny for me was that I played a
little and then I I don't know how yes
yes yeah Oh Dan you have to be pretty
precise with that thing I'm not gonna do
it I'm not gonna do it anymore it's just
something I've got to do my own time I
cuz things I do not know how to use
pulse play because I don't ever use it
I mean it's mainly for revealing people
yeah but this has completely changed
that I use it all the time I love it
I like knowing where people are I mean I
could just sit here right I'm sorry uh
yeah I never got into destiny and then
it kind of took off around the office I
wasn't around I feel like to like play
it enough yeah and then it essentially
people were so far ahead that I was yeah
it's too it I'm like yeah I'm like late
I might like the ferocious there you are
you're attached to that two to one bun
right now I'm just really want to get it
it's like always like a challenge I mean
have I have one
do you get why yeah I missed it too yeah
you did
wasn't that cool actually I'm gonna I'm
gonna punch something I'm playing like
please don't hit me
goddamnit I have a battery - I'm doing
it get off I'll be enough actually test
destinies how I met a few of the people
in the chat right now Bob Jones uh I
think I talked to goob in destiny first
before like maybe using a lot of chat
but oh you know what it was I didn't
have a ps4 at the time now I think about
it and everyone's blowing one ps4 here
I'm super excited for pray me to shadow
war which is August shadow before you
know what's funny is I wouldn't know I
wouldn't know that would be a sequel to
you know I mean like if someone said
that to me I'd be like on it sounds like
a really generic name yeah to clarify
Middle Earth shadow for right it makes
sense because it's like a more higher
slight larger scale battles and like an
actual war boom
Muir come down oh nice move
I was just joining this is glitch in the
frontier title to his newest update on
ps4 Xbox one and PC you can go play it
now if you want after you watch our
stream new two new maps do new game
modes actually so that's what I'm
curious about and people have been
mentioning which of these game modes
that they're gonna be cycling in our
available right now we'll have to check
after this match cuz right now it
doesn't seem like I don't think they
have any the new ones that's possible
it's possible the cuz you've been
English 24/7 playlist which is just a
feel for the new map glitch but on
existing game modes oh my god flight
call online ah honey get back guys
Guillermo Hernandez yes this game is
very worth if you have not played it you
play this one it's just on sale until
like yesterday for like $14 somewhere
yeah that's possible on origin maybe her
let's do this
where you don't and I think they last
update they did something the North
Stars a core ability
who gives me I love the cluster rocket
oh my god oh yeah I got some persona 5
going on the chat I'll chime in on that
while we're playing titanfall to make
sense where is this guy
like a smash
oh you're gonna do that
nice you baited it chef
as I am
Oh No haha
I use my second jump already I need me
to
hahahaha so for those you don't know
anvil one gaming is Ryan Schubert who
works at GameSpot he's re like YouTube
mod and mod for everything so just uh if
you're gonna be spamming the chat don't
say [ __ ] anvil 1 gaming because you're
gonna keep and there's on that unfold
before me and Ryan kind of took care of
it alright still liking this map good
impressions for those just joining yeah
I like this map so far brah
okay it's like it's don't don't waste it
ah damn
you mean wasted like that because I've
totally that I really like it
oh yeah oh yeah oh my god I am so dumb
today
damn Marco Diaz really hates tone matter
Matson last time I'd say thanks Mike
yeah
all right let's take a break from this
let's reset what time we got time Oh
5:13 sorry it's real as you're talking
to me I'm enjoying this chat ah yeah
5:13 p.m. Pacific time okay okay um so
let's see what else we got here so I
guess unfortunately in these modes are
not to be seen soon they would like go
down these are all standards um yeah
maybe they just haven't even added them
to the menu yet like fade it out okay um
what else could we do you want to do a
live fire map on deck sure
hopefully it gives us DAC and not the
other ones sure
fifteen minutes yes real gaming which is
on YouTube just asking about life ion
tech Bob Jones I don't think mark so we
were just talking about that I know of
none of the new game modes are live yet
right now it's just glitched 24/7 which
is the new map glitch with rotating
existing modes marked for death does
sound really good though
that one song we can double check in a
little bit I doubt it's going to be live
in the next estimated wait time 12
minutes that's not gonna work out damn
uh what about now we can't do in there
one play live fire yeah see that right
now these only my modes available
unfortunately because mark for death
sounds dope yeah unfortunately um damn
what you want to do well I think my
lives we thought I think we should play
more of this map right it's about all I
can say Oh what up what other new
teachers Michigan tradition judge
doesn't fire bucket says I'm the mat
cool they removed the Sun flare for a
few maps yeah it's just interesting I
think one of them is exoplanet is
alright exoplanet forward base and
colony alright I can go through some the
Titan nerf sandy pups and hit it [ __ ]
like that
alright cool Titan melee is Rob
mentioned earlier if you were here the
Titan a laser produced area of effect
for all times except Ronin because he
has that sword fixed a bug with Ronin
sword block not always blocking the
intended
damaged small reduction in laser shots
cone angle for ion and that's it for
Titan balancing pilot balance oh you
were talking about this uh can you talk
about that pretty funny thread with the
hollow pilot fans oh yeah apparently
there's in the sub-array oh here we go
the titanfall subreddit people uh her I
don't know there's a small there a group
of them there's a small group of people
who are I guess are like all about the
hologram which I can understand like
I've been tricked by it anyways yeah
these new updates to that ability they
like allowed they allow you to walk
through the hologram to walk through em
Jesus
allow you to walk through the a wall oh
wow and also throughout a wall shield
well amped wall and want a watch and
then crouched while Hult like have the
however I'm crotch as well which is just
essentially another reason or way that
they're going to become more and more
realistic and so the the people who uh
and this I've read were funny they're
just like we grow stronger every update
cuz yeah I mean every time I see it I'm
like I'll give hologram or help yeah
Hallows trout again actually we should
probably check it out yeah to eight more
worth it
[Music]
not much else worth mentioning yeah I
don't think Oh what's what did they do
to the Sidewinder the rocket launcher I
think they made it like longer to lock
that's the Archer has reduced missile
tracking speed that we were talking
about and we'll continue to track
targets but not the extreme out it had
been since the last patch say that again
in explaining reduce missile tracking
speed it'll continue to track targets
but not to the extreme amount it had
been since the last patch yeah that
makes sense
oh damn I just got ret Oh interesting
the crosshair dots no longer turn off
when firing assault rifles and SMGs I
think no they turned off before maybe
this is something Reilly Christensen I
want proof he says he just got his final
pulse blood kill prove it I'm not
falling for it until I see proof
show me that execution
Bob Jones said hologram for life this is
gonna go real well
oh sorry about that um I just knocked
the microphone um everything else just
miscellaneous bug fixes nice
wild 100s this is glitch new map for the
all game modes the other new map is for
live fire only that is called Dec at it
people yep some of those hacen we are
playing on ps4 that's just the platform
that Rob had updated first people asking
why we're not playing on PC Aaron
Sampson on the bar bullpens playing on
PC it seemed like I you know and I kind
of regret I got really far into ps4 and
I was a clash probably I should playing
on PC I had the idea that would go back
and then all my buddies got it my
friends outside of work and I'm getting
it for ps4 and so it's like I don't I
just this one of those things works like
if I'm if I'm not playing on ps4 now I
feel like I'm not like improving like or
you know progressing correctly like like
I still for one like haven't gone
generation 10 on my North Star I want it
bad
all-black North Star with that yeah
wait someone's saying it's not out on PC
yeah pretty sure Aaron's no Aaron is
definitely playing yeah that's on a PC
yeah
what about that devices how do you how
do you whoa do you know do you ember how
big her download was incidentally yeah
that's that's great
ah the download damn I was looking at
the patch notes uh would you I'm not
quite sure someone just asked me how big
the download is like how many it's
probably what a few Meg's nothing major
it's downloaded pretty quick I put my
ps4 on standby and it downloaded like I
feel like they should tell I'm in orem
wet dream 23 we are playing for probably
about another 10 and 15 minutes yeah
being later in the day we don't have as
much time as if we started this morning
unfortunately but uh I don't know and we
can convince people against about to let
us play again on Thursday or Friday on
stream I would stream this every day
yeah I know but I would also screen it
after I got refreshed ah damn you
after I freshened up on my skills
because they're a little ugly right now
clearly really ugly because I just did
that
Exhibit A this is horrible I'm sorry I'm
sorry to everyone watching
yeah someone a lucky buddy
one two three four mentioned the ark
Rene and then pulse blade you want to
try that out say it say it again the ark
grenade and then pulse blade someone
yeah that's a good idea that is a good
idea
oh hi right cuz you're just totally
stunning someone huh
ballin bunny 64 on twitch said on my
titanfall 2 and Xbox one tells me my
profiles not for me to play online even
though I can with Gears of War 4 he's
having a problem with yeah would that
have anything to like so I don't I can't
vouch for Xbox one unfortunately that's
where as the patch
please work
interesting
nice rond button
I am so bad as
yeah ballin bunny sorry I can't really
help you out
yeah Riley Christensen I'm just messing
with you I do want to see that execution
though Rob's at three out of ten
if we get like an attrition some mapper
or it's more I don't know I'm gonna say
just Connor like like all these what on
earth just having no idea hope I want
someone to stand right there
that time for one more match I'd say I'd
say so - oh here we go
I was a decent throb I'm normally pretty
amazing eject eject what do you think
the new Titan will be were you what are
you willing to bet on new Titan not like
prime erect well we know the next two
primes will come at the same time and
that's that's tone and Ronan Ronan would
be cool I would like to see what he
looks like uh new Titan in general I
don't know the bicep man uh MLG frog of
life is really wanting you to use the
sixty-four faction why I don't know
that's fine I'm not a big fan of this
new one to be honest um ah someone asked
to see the new main - I didn't get a
chance to change it so I'll show you the
new main menu also Optimus you get the
chance it's pretty cool uh we shall at
the beginning here it's neat
somebody keeps saying Vanguard that's
the one from campaign right with like
rocket missile launcher and Mike
yeah but that'd be that'd be weak and
that's just a weapon yeah
oh the Vanguard is the one they could
just be a vanguard class Titan gets
swapped between Oliver right that's the
coal campaign storyline right it
wouldn't be a vanguard and I wouldn't
want that you know you want fierce 8101
yeah I'm reading twitch it I want it to
be elemental again I want it to be like
an EMP like that art gun was so cool to
shoot pilots with yeah like that
district 9 gun the Bison will be cool
though seeing how they like Ronan's kind
of melee focused he's pretty melee
focused
um right Ronin and duty would wreck it's
like he would wreck around he we head
towards them and like ronon's more like
a stealthy attack when you can sounds
like Bisons more just full-on like
brawler yeah it sounds weird it sounds
like the opposite of what you like with
Titans which is range right or at least
with Northstar no I F
yeah my favorite Titan being scorch I I
don't know how I feel that bison byeson
sounds cool
switch get me out of my comfort zone I'm
sure I mean I I guess that makes sense
although Ronan's my my second yeah you
know how many is that four or five four
damn yeah like I guess you don't really
have that many um you know there's
really only the Ronin as a male a Titan
to have a second one he sounds like
really intimidating because he could you
know he's got grapples so he feasibly
will pull you towards him and that would
suck as someone who loves North Star I
did not want any part of that
uh yeah I would very much like to uh
find out with the next tightness ooh can
we get this flag yeah we can oh oh yeah
I wonder when we'll get it to when did
this game release October yeah right
October at some point that was what they
do you think they'd wait a year to do a
new Titan or no asking like really like
they wait for like maybe I don't know
III announced minish summer announcement
damn close yeah yeah you could see I
could see it dropping at maybe III I
could be cool
fierce
dat wants to know does anyone still play
this game actively even before this
update and I will say that I do
clearly with my extreme skill but I play
a lot not so much lately but these
updates definitely bring me back and
then I'll go I'll go probably pretty
strong for a few weeks I don't know when
the last time you played unfortunately I
was like the last update I think times
been taken up by playing games for work
no I know that's and that's how I feel
as well like oh [ __ ] I would 100% would
keep playing this if I didn't was right
on others right yeah like I'd play
tonight but I got to play somehow last
yeah maybe I'll get her a couple runs in
I I needed like get back into this game
I split had slipped
Craver fun fact of the day did you know
that shoes are supposed to be worn on
your feet it's a really good fun fact
you're encouraging this well we don't
have much time left so I don't really
care
oh you know that was totally intentional
Mike I got shot I just wanted to do it I
wanted to get 10 of those kills now it's
all I think about
that's the probably sex acute challenges
that you just become the anti team
player like you support not like II
believe like I think the the first
execution the unlock was like pretty
sure was 50 executions yep
it was crazy lot for like a good five
hours like everyone who played with me
hated me both sides of the team like
either one
there was one that dry got a guy
probably like five times executions yeah
I didn't bother with that unfortunately
I wonder if that's still the challenge
what's that rifle called she was just
using an obscene
man this guy's using stem good call oh
well I know that was there there he goes
I like this wall in the middle here
that's really neat partition of sorts
yeah we'll just see someone like on the
other side run by you and you can't
really anything about it trying to get
over it this is neat all right at it
dude this is pathetic
288 8 I was gonna say you forgetting
another digit how sweet ballin Bunny's
got his update rats
that's crazy things that when this game
came out like the the first patch they
did was uh whenever you fired your
weapon you would lose a cloak the cloak
ability would turn off like that for
time they didn't have that so I just
never run around you would flicker a
little bit but you just be wrecking like
it I just imagine them pulling back like
all right look at the stats holy Sh what
cloak and IVA shotgun we gotta do
something about this it's like the
celery man paul rudd gift reaction he's
like oh okay now okay Paul your wife's
on the phone it is a emergency not now I
have more board work to do
and I've been perfect for a pulse play
oh wow that was pretty quick my shooting
white boy that's his name right white
port or 20 calm so I like that website
like it pick the craver I'll pick the
craver for however many seconds I have
left
this will be interesting
it's guys good
you said he wish you said that white boy
thing just because just causes a fun
game Just Cause 3 i I never finished it
that games is this the single or the
campaign story was this really week
he didn't really have he liked it was
fun to like mess around I didn't care at
all I just [ __ ] around alright let's
try this I've not done this on why we go
oh
does it work but he's tricky on the gum
here Oh nailed it damn bullet drop from
that far away yeah
do they do anything to this gun is that
why they want to see it are they just
messing with me cuz oh I don't mind
because I suck right now so I'm as well
I don't think the day through the craver
nothing I think they're just messing
with you good cuz that's gonna be it
ooh that's cool Ronen prime looking a
lot like a samurai hot I apologize let's
cut out of the gameplay thank you guys
for watching and witnessing own inch of
you sucking but hey whatever you win
some you lose some
yeah yeah later in the day than we
normally stream but tomorrow normal time
for the lobby at 11:00 a.m. Pacific
Wednesday as usual we're gonna be
talking about outlast - Dragon Quest
Heroes Dawn of War 3 Call of Duty World
War 2 which also reminds me starting at
9:00 a.m. tomorrow Pacific we will be
playing Call of Duty World War 2 games
until the announcement in the trailer
but the trailer yeah I'll do World War 2
yeah she fund what else going on
tomorrow lobby lobby something later and
they will might play a titanfall 2 later
in the week yeah
try squeeze that in cool i'ma work work
on my game word word alright cool
everybody thanks for joining Felix which
youtube games my chats we always
appreciate participating coming to hang
out we know it's late in the day for
some of you on the East Coast and
elsewhere but yeah like I said we'll see
you tomorrow we're looking forward to it
definitely thanks Rob so you guys thank
you Mike